y la frecuencia que observamos estando
junto a una bocina está determinada por
la tasa en la cual los picos de la onda
llegan a donde nos encontramos si la
bocina se dirige hacia nosotros
escucharemos una frecuencia mayor y si
la bocina se aleja de nosotros
escucharemos una frecuencia más baja
pero qué pasa si somos nosotros quienes
nos acercamos a la bocina escucharemos
una frecuencia mayor porque más picos de
onda nos van a tocar por segundo y si
nos alejamos de la bocina vamos a
escuchar una frecuencia más baja porque
menos máximos de onda nos van a tocar
por segundo pero como encontramos la
frecuencia exacta que escuchamos para
descubrirlo veamos más de cerca qué es
lo que ocurre digamos que un máximo de
onda acaba de llegar a donde nos
encontramos el tiempo que le toma a otro
máximo de onda llegar a donde nos
encontramos será el periodo que
observamos ya que es el tiempo que
observamos entre máximos de onda si nos
encontramos en reposo simplemente
tendremos que esperar a que llegue
y otro máximo de onda a donde nos
encontramos y el periodo que observamos
será el periodo real de la onda pero si
nos acercamos a la bocina oa la fuente
de la onda no tendremos que esperar
tanto tiempo ya que estamos acercándonos
hacia dónde viene la onda por lo que nos
vamos a encontrar a mitad del camino y
podemos calcular cuánto tiempo va a
llegar para que el siguiente máximo de
onda nos toque ese es el período que
vamos a observar y experimentar digamos
que nos movemos con una rapidez
constante y le llamaremos ve o bs que es
la rapidez del observador la distancia
que viajamos para alcanzar el siguiente
máximo de onda será nuestra rapidez
multiplicada por el tiempo que nos lleva
a llegar ahí pero este tiempo será el
periodo que observemos ya que será el
tiempo que experimentamos entre máximos
de onda así que escribimos el tiempo
como 'the o bs porque es el tiempo del
observador o el periodo del observador
de forma similar la distancia que va a
viajar el siguiente máximo de onda
cuando no se encuentre va a ser la
rapidez de la onda b w
por ese mismo periodo de tiempo el
período de tiempo que estamos observando
pero qué hacemos ahora sabemos que la
distancia entre los máximos de la onda
es la longitud de onda no la longitud de
onda del observador sino la longitud de
la onda emitida por la fuente o nuestra
bocina mientras se encuentra en reposo
si agregamos la distancia que nosotros
recurrimos y la sumamos a la distancia
que recorrió el siguiente máximo de onda
para encontrarse con nosotros
tendrá que ser igual a una longitud de
onda y ahora podemos sacar el factor
común de tves y si despejamos el periodo
del observador veremos que es igual a la
longitud de onda de la fuente dividida
entre la rapidez de la onda más la
rapidez del observador y ésta es una
buena ecuación para encontrar el periodo
experimentado por un observador en
movimiento aunque el problema aquí está
en que en un lado tenemos periodo y del
otro lado tenemos longitud de onda y si
queremos comparar manzanas con manzanas
podemos poner esta longitud de onda en
término
de periodo y lo hacemos mediante esta
fórmula la velocidad es igual a la
longitud de onda de la fuente entre el
periodo de la fuente y ya que esta
longitud de onda fue la longitud de onda
de la fuente tendremos que usar el
periodo de la fuente que es la onda
emitida por la bocina no el periodo del
observador si despejamos la longitud de
onda nos queda que la velocidad de la
onda multiplicada por el periodo de la
fuente es igual a la longitud de onda de
la fuente así que sustituimos esta
expresión en lugar de la longitud de
onda y nos queda una nueva ecuación que
nos dice que el periodo experimentado
por el observador va a ser igual a la
rapidez de la onda multiplicado por el
periodo de la fuente dividido entre la
rapidez de la onda más la rapidez del
observador y esta es una buena ecuación
para encontrar el periodo experimentado
por el observador pero
físicos y otras personas prefieren
hablar en términos de frecuencia y no en
términos de periodos por lo que podemos
convertir este anunciado que relaciona
periodos a un enunciado que relacione
frecuencias y esto lo hacemos al
invertir a ambos lados y nos queda que
el inverso del período observado es
igual a la rapidez de la onda más la
rapidez del observador dividido entre la
rapidez de la onda multiplicada por el
periodo de la fuente pero noten que el
inverso del periodo es la frecuencia
experimentada por el observador y del
otro lado voy a sacar como factor el
inverso del periodo de la fuente que nos
deja la rapidez de la onda más la
rapidez del observador dividido entre la
rapidez de la onda y para el paso final
ponemos todo esto en términos de
frecuencia al notar que el inverso del
periodo de la fuente es la frecuencia de
la fuente así que si ya lo encontramos
esta es la fórmula para encontrar la
frecuencia experimentada para el
observador que se acerca a la fuente
conforme aumenta la velocidad del
observador también va a aumentar la
frecuencia experimentada por este
observador el sonido será más alto o más
agudo pero noten que esta fórmula sólo
funciona para un observador que se
acerca a la fuente y en semos y el
observador se aleja de la fuente bueno
vamos a comenzar desde el principio te
estaba bromeando ya que nos estamos
alejando de la bocina en lugar de
estarnos acercando hacia ella podemos
poner un signo negativo acá en lugar del
signo positivo y aquí lo tenemos una
sola ecuación que describe el
desplazamiento doppler para un
observador que se acerca o se aleja de
la fuente y esta fuente debe de estar
estacionaria usamos el signo de suma
cuando nos estamos acercando a esta
fuente estacionaria y usamos el signo de
menos cuando nos estamos alejando de
esta fuente estacionaria